hey I think you're gonna like this this
is a little bit of a break from the
persistently depressing news for only
slightly depressing news that also has a
funny component so Fox News brings on a
doctor and the doctor is interviewed by
anchor Martha McCallum the doctor was
completely unwilling to accept even a
little bit of Martha McCallum's bogus
framing of questions he gave her a 60
second answer that instantly shut down
the interview martha maccallum saying
right away
thanks doc we'll talk to you later so
let me set this up for you this is dr.
Richie Desai he's the chief medical
officer at osmosis dr. Desai is an
expert in infectious disease much like
Anthony Fauci dr. Desai is not just a
doctor but he is a doctor who
specializes in exactly what we're
dealing with here the corona virus
pandemic dr. Desai recently led Khan
Academy's medicine portal we're talking
about a scholar an academic a doctor and
he will not take Martha McCallum's
biessed martha maccallum frames up a
question about you know we're told about
millions of tests being available dr.
Desai immediately starts just shaking
his head no and then in 60 seconds
explains basically everything we need to
know about the testing Fiasco we knew
about the issue of testing for a long
time we knew the virus was coming we did
nothing while South Korea did everything
check this out this is how you ensure no
follow-up questions from fox news
anchors now what we hear every night is
that the test that there are millions of
tests available and yet we don't have
that pin prank blood test that you can
just sort of get you know at your local
doctor in know in 15 minutes but they're
yeah they're working on it they should
have no work on it for months so the
fact is we knew about this from the WHI
went December 31st 2019 so last year we
knew about this we knew coronavirus is
coming we knew as the restroom disease
we knew as person person why is it that
it's this week that the FDA finally
approved these kind of new Abbott lab
testing which by the way is one test at
a time it's a great test but it's
test at a time it's different than the
labs that are doing mass testing right
so this is a wonderful test don't get me
wrong but it's one test for 15 minutes
that's wonderful but it's not the same
volume that you really need this is
better for kind of outpatient clinics
and things like that we needed this
months ago you look at Korea Korea South
Korea and the u.s. had their first
official confirmed case on the same date
January 19th January 19th you look at
what South Korea did and what we did
their population is one-sixth of ours
look at the cases they have look at the
mortality they have it's a trifle
compared to what we're dealing with
right now because we've had a very weak
response and they had a really strong
response doctor thank you very
interesting to talk to you dr. Desai I
hope you'll come back as we move through
this difficult period in the country dr.
Desai thank you very much sir
so martha maccallum goes silent and ends
the interview no follow-up just buh-bye
back to Donald Trump's propaganda claims
now there's speculation that that delay
when dr. Desai stops speaking before
martha maccallum starts speaking was
because a producer was in her ear
telling her end the interview and wrap
it up that's an interestingly dramatic
romanticized kind of narrative it might
have just been a delay with dr. Desai's
connection we don't really know but
visually very very compelling and again
regarding the tests this is a really
important point that dr. Desai makes the
Abbott point of care test that takes 15
minutes it's a really great thing that
we have this because it's great for
health care providers to be able to run
the tests in-house rather than having to
send them out it reduces the amount of
time that you have to wait for any one
individual test but it's important to
understand as dr. Desai points out the
machine can run one test at a time the
results take five to 15 minutes that
means you can test four people per hour
that's not good in a lot of ways
particularly in a lot of these more
densely populated areas so you know it's
it's a good thing that the test is a
point-of-care test that it can all be
done in-house but at the same time a lot
of these other tests are done in large
swaths you can test a hue
of samples at once get a lot of people
results very quickly if you have several
hundred people that you've tested and
you can only run four per hour through a
machine you're still going to get a huge
amount of backup any new testing
capacity is good very important to
understand but dr. Desai accurately
pointing out that as with almost
everything Donald Trump is obviously
over selling it we'll have more coverage
of testing on the David Pakman show
instagram page at david pakman show
while you're there check out my
Instagram David Pakman I'll soon be
filming a full behind-the-scenes of the
home studio which I think a lot of
people are going to look at very
strongly that's my that's my expectation
anyway let me tell you real quick about
one of our sponsors cuts clothing they
offer super quality men's t-shirts and
they're giving you 15% off when you go
to david pakman.com slash cuts that's
see UTS because solid color t-shirts are
a really important staple in pretty much
every guy's wardrobe I think it's really
important not to overlook the value of
having t-shirts you love wearing
t-shirts from cuts clothing have been a
game changer for me and as a company all
they deal with our men's solid color
t-shirts so they actually put a ton of
thought into the comfort the style the
durability of the t-shirts they make
they fit perfectly they're not scratchy
they don't shrink they don't fade they
don't stretch out over time like so many
other t-shirts they're really the most
comfortable t-shirts I've owned and they
look great this right here that I'm
wearing on YouTube is the split hem crew
neck t-shirt very soft fits me perfectly
it's the ideal length go take a look at
what they offer and once you have it you
are really going to see and feel the
difference their slogan is it's the only
shirt worth wearing you will see why and
you'll get 15% off when you do it by
going to david pakman.com slash cuts
that's david pakman.com slash c UTS